and some tells me times like this
maybe we are going through the process
where some of these businesses need to
go out of business and make some room
for the new entrepreneur the small
business owners to come up and get
access to that sun because maybe they
have a better proposition to the
customer that's better than the bigger
guys who for years been getting bailed
out by governments that give them money
saying hey don't worry about it i know
your lobbyist behind closed doors you're
helping my election let's make sure we
bail these guys out let's make sure we
bail these guys out maybe it's time we
let these guys go out of business so the
next generation of entrepreneurs the
next generation of small business owners
starts getting an opportunity to have a
better product better service better
propositions for the customers so the
next time you hear about this whole
thing of
too big to fail let's spell them out
maybe it's okay for some of these guys
to go out of business what do you think
about it